in the 1800's most paintings looked like
this meet at colors complex scenes and
lots of mythological stuff but in 1865
something came along that was so
different it caused shock and horror and
outrage the bodies putrifying color
caused the horror of the malasana times
the undefinable terror of a painted core
faces stupid
her skin cadaverous she does not have a
human form the painting is called
Olympia and it changed the art world
forever
Anwar MANET painted Olympia in 1863 when
Paris was the cultural center of the
world and at the centre of this cultural
center was the Academy of Fine Arts the
Academy was made up of upper-crust art
critics that worshipped the Italian
Renaissance painters of 300 years prior
you know Michelangelo Raphael Botticelli
Titian and at the Paris salon the
Academy's legendary annual art show
they only displayed arts that mimic the
Renaissance style to determine who made
the cut they had a bunch of rules
first and foremost great art was
supposed to convey a moral or
intellectual message and all acceptable
art fell into one of five categories
ranked by their capacity to deliver
those messages landscapes and still
lifes were at the bottom and in the
middle are portraits and genre paintings
which are mostly quaint scenes of poor
or foreign subjects painted for the rich
and at the top of the list was history
painting the Academy's darling
these depicted major historical or
mythical moments they were considered
the best at providing an ethical or
moral lesson like depictions of The
Birth of Venus showing the goddess
emerging fully formed in the ocean a
symbol of womanly perfection and divine
love which brings us to the second set
of rules equally important to what was
painted was how it was painted take that
painting of The Birth of Venus it's the
kind of painting the Academy loved its
subjects are idealized prettified
visions of the world smooth and
beautiful with no body hair and flawless
skin the painting follows the rules of
depth and perspective meaning it looks
like it could exist in the real world
and the scene is complex and layered
there's a lot going on its colors are
ones you'd find in nature they aren't
too saturated or harsh and the
brushstrokes are smooth so smooth that
they're nearly invisible on the canvas
for a long time really the only way to
become a successful artists was to
follow the Academy's rules which makes
Manet's Olympia all the more an outlier
check out this painting from Renaissance
master Titian from 1538 look familiar it
should MANET painted Olympia as a direct
riff on Titian Venus of Urbino but
there's a recent mayonnaise painting
ruffled so many feathers when it hung in
a salon for starters the name Olympia
was a popular pseudonym for sex workers
many took a beloved instantly
recognizable painting and corrupted it
subbing in a common sex worker for the
morally upright goddess of love and
fertility there's not much room for a
sex worker in the hierarchy of genres
there's also how many paid Olympia that
really changed things many use stark and
unnatural colors they give Olympia cold
and harsh look and look at how rough and
textured mayonnaise brushstrokes are
compared to Titian zim perceptible ones
and unlike Titian 'z mayonnaise painting
doesn't seem to exist in real space it's
much flatter and less complex and beyond
the rules the two paintings just feel
different Venus lounges while Olympia
sits at attention
Venus's maids placed furs in a chest
probably a wedding gift
Olympia's maid brings her flowers likely
from one of her regular customers and
compared their hands people really
didn't like Olympia Stan's fingers one
critic claims she was mocking the pose
of Venus with a hand shamelessly flexed
where Venus is warm and inviting
Olympia is tense and stiff it's as if
Venus invites you to look at her wall
would be a confronts you almost like
she's shaming you for intruding
it's not totally clear why the Academy
chose to display many's rule-breaking
painting but it probably had something
to do with his growing popularity you
can see his influence so clearly and
what came next he led the charge towards
modernism in the late 1800s starting
with the Impressionists Monet Degas who
adopted his penchant for modern themes
and loosened brushstrokes but it's not
just the impressionist suomen a more
than anything
Olympia's proof that no one entity gets
to decide what art should look like and
we look back on the history of art we
don't remember the people were really
good at followed the rules we remember
the people who moved the needle forward
[Music]
you